يزعم انه جاء الى النرويج طلبا للوجوب بعد
فراره من مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه اعتقل حرس
الحدود في النرويج اندري مدفيديف في
الثالث عشر من يناير الشاب ذو الس 26 عاما
دخل الى البلاد عبر قريه صغيره تقع على
طول الحدود مع روسيا بحسب مقابله نشرها
موقع منظمه جولاك روسيه غير الحكوميه هرب
الشاب تحت نيران فاجنر عندما كنت على
الجليد سمعت كلابا تنبح اصدرت رايت اشخاص
يحملون مصابيح على بعد حوالي 150 متر
ويرضون سمعت طلقتين
حاليا تدرس السلطات النرويجيه قضيته
مهم للغايه من الضروري دراسه الملف بعنايه
من هو من اين جاء هل ما يدعيه صحيح
نقيم كل ذلك مع كل من يطلب اللجوء في
النرويج
لكن من الواضح
سيتم فحصها بدقه
النيجر
قائد وحده قبل انشقاقه يقول انه شهيد
عمليات اعدام وانتقام دفعته الى الفرار
يؤكد ايضا انه مستعد لقوله
عن فاجنر ومؤسسها يبكي نيبر الذي يدعي في
هذا الفيديو منح العفو لمدانين روس مقابل
مشاركتهم في القتال في اوكرانيا